hey everyone it's nurse Sarah with
registered nurse rn.com in this video
I'm going to demonstrate how to take a
flowflex covid-19 antigen home test so
let's get started first you want to wash
your hands and if you're performing this
test on someone else you'll want to put
on gloves then open up your kit and in
the kit you should find a test cassette
a disposable nasal swab and an
extraction buffer tube tear open the
extraction buffer to packaging and pull
back the foil on the top of the tube and
then place the tube on the perforated
Circle that is on the box next open up
the nasal swab packaging at the stick
end and remove the stick from the
packaging to collect the sample insert
the swab into one nostril about a half
to three fourth inch once inserted swab
the inside of the nostril wall in a
circular motion about five times and
this should take around 15 seconds to do
when you're done with that nostril will
go to the next nostril and repeat the
same procedure then remove the swab from
the nose and place in the extraction
buffer tube and then swirl the swab
around in this solution for 30 seconds
once that's complete you'll want to
squeeze the tube and rotate that swab
around five times then while squeezing
the tube still you're going to remove
the swab and dispose of the swab then
attach The Dropper tip onto the tube and
mix the solution and your specimen in
the tube by swirling it around or
flicking the bottom of the tube now it's
time to place your sample into the
actual test cassette she'll be dropping
four drops of your specimen from the
tube into the sample well now we're
looking for a line at the T part which
is the actual test part if a line pops
up here that means it's positive but we
need to wait 15 minutes to see what the
results are and if after 50 minutes no
line appears here the test is negative
now one thing to note with this test the
results are not valid after 30 minutes
so here is what a positive test result
looks like notice there's a line in the
control area and the test area and this
is what a negative test result looks
like there's a line in the control area
but there is not a line in the test area
Okay so that wraps up this video if
you'd like to watch more videos in this
series you can access the link in the
description below